all right so the director of this movie
Brad Anderson clearly likes to make his
actors do extreme things
Christian Bale lost an absurd amount of
weight for the machinist and in this one
there is a possibility that there are
birds nesting in Halle Berry's hair the
call is directed by Brad Anderson and it
stars Halle Berry and Abigail Breslin
now this movie is about a 911 dispatch
operator she gets a nine one one call
one day that there is a man inside a
girl's house she's trying to hide from
him and Halle Berry's trying to instruct
her about how to be safe that goes wrong
and that disturbs Halle Berry's
character greatly and she can't be a
dispatch operator for a while because
it's just gotten too close to her and
she has to separate herself from that
event one day she is forced to pick up
the headset again and answer a call it
just so happens to be Abigail breslin's
character who has been locked inside the
trunk of a car and Halle Berry suspects
that this kidnapping could possibly be
related to the first one now the trailer
for this movie truly looked awful I had
no idea what to expect going into this
movie because it just looked really like
a made-for-tv movie and I was really
surprised too because I actually loved
The Machinist I thought it was an
excellent twilight zone like thriller
with a knockout performance that was
sadly looked over by the Oscars by
Christian Bale but this movie just looks
so cliched and silly and honestly if you
watch the trailer for this movie I can
tell you've pretty much seen the major
portions of each act so please if you're
interested in seeing this film do not
watch the trailer because it gave away
way too much and this film in my opinion
is okay it's not terrible and it's not
that great there are definitely moments
in this movie that I was invested in
where I was riveted by the action where
I was riveted by the characters and
maybe a few moments in the movie that
seemed like okay this is actually a
pretty intense scene here unfortunately
I saw the trailer for the movie and I
knew the ending of like each scene but
it's not just that this movie can get a
little bit ludicrous now I have two
friends who are actually 911 police
dispatchers and I was curious about how
accurate the film was and they saw the
same screening with me so after the film
I asked them you know how'd they do and
they said it was actually surprisingly
pretty well-rounded and accurate in
regards to how things are the technology
was a little better for the dispatchers
for what they have in the movie than
what we have here in Cleveland but they
did say that it was surprisingly
accurate and so for that reason
I gotta get the film props because
that's something I wouldn't know about
since I know nothing about that
but according to my friends the movie
did a good job of handling that
accurately so if you are a policeman or
a police dispatcher or know somebody who
is
you can probably watch this movie
without being incredibly annoyed with
all the factual errors it makes Halle
Berry is really good in this movie
actually I thought she did a good job
for this film her role requires a lot of
emotion and I thought that she gave what
her character needed to this movie and I
was impressed with her performance
now abigail breslin I do like her as an
actress I've liked her ever since I saw
her in science little girl in signs a
little charming cute little girl came
on-screen complaining about water and it
was great she was amazing and little
miss sunshine as well oscar-nominated
role there but in this movie I really
feel like she just over acted the entire
movie and I get it you're in a situation
where you are more than likely thinking
I'm going to die but the way Anderson
directed this movie was he got so many
horrific aliy close-up shots like
literally with the camera like bumping
against her face like it was like
obviously right here like her face was
beginning to appear rounded as if he was
using a fisheye lens just to get like
right up in her face and when she's
crying and whimpering and everything it
can get a little bit annoying it just it
didn't feel real it felt extremely
forced I wouldn't say she was terrible
in the movie I just think that she just
went too far with it also the main
kidnapper in this film is a disturbing
absurdly creepy man but he's given
absolutely no real motive you never
really understand exactly what is going
on with him they never even attempt to
explain it and whenever a killer is just
kind of passed off as oh he's insane I
just feel like that's a cop-out it's
just a lazy way of writing a movie where
you don't actually give your killer any
type of real motive for doing the things
that he's doing he's just a nutjob and I
know people like that exist but for
entertainment purposes I would have
liked a more viable explanation the
movie isn't poorly directed but there's
nothing terribly remarkable about it
except for the fact that this guy has a
good way of showing you really close up
intense images that can kind of get
under your skin he did it a little bit
too much though and I feel like Brad
Anderson could have possibly held back a
little bit in this movie by using the
camera as a way to express intensity
where he should have had the characters
and the dialogue be able to express that
intent to
better than just kind of shoving a
camera a centimeter away from the main
actresses I but the call was not a
terrible movie it did feature a really
good performance by Halle Berry it had
some good set pieces some good moments
where I was invested in the tension but
something I haven't mentioned without
spoiling anything is that the last 20
minutes of this movie are absurd it
loses almost all credibility to the film
set up before that and it just didn't
work for me but overall I will say that
the call is possibly a good rental just
to pass the time I'm going to give it a
C+ thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you liked this review you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]